vous allez me faire l'amour maintenant
je ne fais pas là moi je pèse
brutalement est né comme ça allait
[Musique]
ah je comprends mieux tout cet attirail
ça veut dire qu'il est sadique cet
adjectif sadique il provient du fameux
marquis de sade un aventurier libertins
du xviiie siècle
dans cette vidéo je vous propose de
remonter à la source du sadisme la vie
du scandaleux marquis de sade
je suis romain et vous êtes sur mille
îles et de culture générale
[Musique]
comme je voulais faire une synthèse de
ce qu'est le sadisme du marquis de sade
et que je ne trouvais aucun article où
aucun manuel pouvant m'éclairer sur le
sujet j'ai lu cette belle biographie de
maurice les verts et comme le sadisme à
d'abord été incarnée par le sulfureux
marquis avant d'être théorisé dans ses
écrits je vais vous en donner une idée
en dix coups de fouet
regardez bien la vidéo jusqu'au bout
parce que les derniers valent le détour
[Musique]
en regardant les choses d'un point de
vue déterministe tous les ingrédients
étaient réunis pour faire du marquis de
sade un scandaleux libertin déjà son
père le comte de sade est l un des plus
brillants modèle de libertin sous le
règne de louis 15 ensuite le marquis a
été arraché à sa mère à l'âge de 4 et
puis il a été élevé en partie chez son
oncle la baie de saab un abbé me bertin
qui faisait beaucoup rire voltaire en
faisant voeu de chasteté alors qu'il
vivait avec deux femmes dans une
forteresse où il faisait aussi venir des
prostituées enfin le jeune marquis de
sade a également passé du temps dans des
établissements religieux ou les
châtiments corporels l'homosexualité et
la pédophilie était monnaie courante à
l'époque le sadisme du marquis de sade
s'explique en partie par son mépris de
classe
enfant il a été élevé avec la conviction
aristocratique d'appartenir à une espèce
supérieure
très tôt il se croit au dessus des
autres est autorisé à s'en servir avec
sa nature despotique il a également subi
les influences du conte de charles est
le tuteur de son premier compagnon de
jeu louis joseph de beauce
or ce qu'on passait pour un des
personnages les plus sadiques de son
temps par exemple il s'amusait à tirer
sur des gens qui passaient simplement
dans son champ de vision ou sur des
ouvriers qui travaillaient en hauteur et
après il se faisait gracié par louis 15
d'ailleurs pour la petite anecdote une
fois le roi lui aurait répondu ce mot
sublime monsieur la grâce que vous
demandez est dû à votre rang et à votre
qualité de prince du sang mais je
l'accorderait plus vous en doutiez
encore à celui qui vous en fera autant
toute sa vie le marquis de sade a montré
beaucoup de morgue et il éprouvait un
grand mépris à l'égard de tous ceux qui
n'étaient pas de son rang et ils
traitaient violemment sans aucun megami
reconnaissance les personnes qui
travaillaient pour lui
souvenez vous de ça pour le coup de
fouet numéro 7
[Musique]
le marquis de sade et est un grand
passionné théâtre qu'il a assidûment
pratiqué au célèbre lycée louis le grand
et c'est très probablement ce qui
explique une particularité majeure du
sadisme la théâtralité le marquis et le
metteur en scène de ces parties fines
ils commandent les postures focalise le
plaisir sur certaines parties du corps
ils composent les selles organise les
groupes des places et rassemble les
partenaires il insiste pour soigner les
détails quant au vrai théâtre
ce n'est que tard dans sa vie à partir
de la 50ème qu'il essaie de faire
représenter ces pièces à paris et en
province
mais avec très peu de succès parce que
les comités de lecture trouvé son
travail ou trop médiocres ou trop
choquant pour la petite anecdote là où
il a pu laisser s'épanouir son talent de
metteur en scène c'est à l'asile de
charenton dont le directeur qui se prend
d'affection pour lui est convaincu que
le théâtre peut guérir la folie
ce qui est assez drôle d'ailleurs c'est
que le marquis attribuer les rôles en
fonction de la démence par exemple il
donne à un malade convaincu d'être
l'homme le plus riche du monde le rôle
d'un grand banquier mais le problème
c'est que ça aggrave la folie
[Musique]
le marquis de sade est totalement athée
et il a d'ailleurs rédigé et prononcé
des discours enflammés
à propos de sa conviction lors de la
révolution française à nouveau je vous
invite encore à retenir ce point pour le
septième coup de fouet de son point de
vue tout divinité est simplement une
stupide illusion qui inspire des
cérémonies grotesque c'est pour ça que
sur le plan du plaisir le blasphème
provoque chez lui une grande jouissance
au point qu'il dit qu'il faudrait
inventer dieu s'il n'existait pas pour
qu'il puisse avoir le plaisir de
m'insulter
c'est d'ailleurs cet aspect qui est à
l'origine du premier grand scandale la
sphère d'arcueil en 1768 ils auraient
séquestré et fouettées jusqu'au sang une
mendiante mais surtout comme c'était le
dimanche de pâques
il l'aurait obligée à se confesser à lui
pendant qu'il la flageller cependant il
n'est pas bien sûr que les choses se
soient exactement passé comme ça c'est
ce premier scandale la sphère d'arcueil
qui a créé la légende reprise et
amplifiée jusque dans la presse
étrangère
or comme on peut l'imaginer même si le
marquer tout sauf un enfant de choeur
ces actes n'ont pas échappé au phénomène
de la rumeur et du téléphone arabe en
fait sad était loin d'être le seul
aristocrate a profité de son statut de
son ascendance sociale et de son aisance
financière pour infliger des sévices à
des individus du peuple particulièrement
fragilisés comme des prostituées ou des
orphelins mais plusieurs facteurs
étaient réunis pour transformer un fait
divers somme toute plutôt banal pour
l'époque en un scandale public
tout d'abord on est vingt ans avant la
révolution l opinion publique est lassé
de voir la justice épargne et les nobles
pour les sévices sexuels ensuite les
mentalités sont encore très religieuse
et la dimension blasphématoire de la
sphère d'arcueil ne peut qu'en décupler
le scandale mais aussi le marquis avait
de puissants ennemis qu'il devait à son
affiliation à la maison de condé une
branche des bourbons et inversement ça
n'avait quasiment pas d'avis il
organisait ces parties fines quasiment
pour lui seul et plus généralement il y
avait vraiment négligé son réseau
personnel comme son père d'ailleurs tous
ces facteurs laissent à penser que les
crimes du marquis ont probablement été
exagérée qu'il était un peu le bouquet
lycéens du peuple et de la presse en
tant qu'incarnation de la corruption de
la noblesse
mais bon il faut aussi voir à la
responsabilité du marquis
[Musique]
ce qui m'a marqué de manière globale
dans cette biographie c'est la profonde
insouciance du marquis et ça à tous les
plans c'est vrai tout d'abord de son
libertinage
comme j'ai déjà dit ça de fréquenter les
prostituées et organiser des soirées au
vu et au su de tout le monde
il avait plusieurs lieux dévolus à ses
plaisirs personnels la police des moeurs
la bonne société et sa belle famille
tout le monde était au courant
ensuite c'était d'autant plus ostensible
que ça lui coûtait vraiment un bras
comme beaucoup de noble de son époque le
marquis dépenser sans compter
faisait systématiquement des dettes à
droite et à gauche à part harceler son
notaire pour qu'ils lui envoient
toujours plus d'argent toujours plus
vite
il était indifférent à sa situation
financière si bien qu'il a finie
totalement ruiné en ayant mangé une
bonne partie de l'héritage de ses
enfants
enfin il était aussi insouciant sur le
plan judiciaire alors même que sa belle
famille avait remué ciel et terre pour
sauver sa réputation et surtout la leur
et lui éviter la prison voire
l'exécution et il recommencer de plus
belle saison comme les drogués il promet
il se cache un moment puis il retombe
dans la bible de son addiction à la fin
sa belle famille on a eu tellement marre
que c'est elle qui a insisté auprès du
pouvoir pour que le marquis soit gardé
entre quatre murs là où il pourrait
faire le moins de mal possible mais
voilà les événements ou écourter sa
détention
[Musique]
le marquis est exfiltré vers une autre
prison
une dizaine de jours avant la prise de
la bastille le 14 juillet et grâce à
l'exaspération de la population à
l'égard des détentions arbitraires
il est libéré début avril 1790 et c'est
là en pleine révolution française que
commencer un autre chapitre de la
légende mais pour le coup totalement
fictif pour faire court le marquis est
passé à la postérité comme un
révolutionnaire de premier plan comme
l'incarnation des victimes de
l'arbitraire monarchique et de l'esprit
de liberté et d'égalité qui soufflait
alors sur la face est là rappelez vous
du deuxième coup de fouet son mépris de
classe c'est bien vrai que marc qui a
pris part aux événements qu'il a été un
citoyen très actif mais ce que les
recherches pointues du biographe révèle
c'est qu'il l'a fait purement et
simplement par reporte une isme déjà ils
à cacher ses origines changer son nom
supprimer sa particule et il se faisait
passer pour un homme de lettres sans le
sou ensuite il était très actif en sous
main pour protéger son patrimoine des
violence révolutionnaire
enfin qui peut croire une seconde qui
souscrivaient à l'idéal de l'égalité lui
l'aristocrate si attaché à son nom est
par nature si méprisant à l'égard du
peuple
la supercherie aurait pu durer longtemps
mais très paradoxalement le marquis a
perdu son crédit auprès de sa section
révolutionnaire en refusant d'avaliser
une condamnation à mort
c'est très étonnant mais ça le fut le
premier écrivain français à s'insurger
contre la peine de mort
[Musique]
c'était inévitable étant donnée son
insouciance saad a passé un tiers de sa
vie entre quatre murs et à lire sa
biographie
j'ai l'impression que c'est cet
enfermement qui a permis la traduction
de son expérience de libertin en une
oeuvre littéraire
alors certes le marquis c'était très tôt
passionné pour la littérature
mais pour ce qui est de l'écriture il
était d'abord attiré plutôt vers des
oeuvres historiques ou des récits de
voyage par exemple à partir de son exil
forcé en italie pour échapper à la
justice française en prison le personnel
est plutôt laxiste a sonné gamme et il
ne peut bien sûr plus nous organiser les
orgies dont il a le secret alors ils se
masturbent comme on fume des cigarettes
il a quelques rapports sexuels mais
c'est loin de pouvoir satisfaire ses
goûts extrême
du coup il donne libre cours à son
imagination sur le papier il écrit il
produit un rythme impressionnant en
s'inspirant de ses orgies et il y
mélange des considérations
philosophiques ses premiers livres ne
lui permettent pas de vivre de sa plume
comme il l'espérait mais ils connaissent
un certain succès dû à leur teneur en
transgression de libertin scandaleux le
marquis de sade devient écrivain maudit
[Musique]
c'est la publication de justin son
oeuvre emblématique en 1791 qui a fait
de sa bien une épithète maudite symbole
du mal absolu
les écrits du marquis sont si choquant
qui sont mises à l'index b que la
ceinture se resserre et forcément cette
interdiction accroît aussi leur
notoriété est comme ça assez goûté de la
prison ces avances ont publié
anonymement et igny farouchement en être
l'auteur allant même jusqu'à les
condamner fermement par écrit en même
temps c'était peut-être plus sage est en
effet la particularité de l'oeuvre de
saad
c'est qu'elle ne relève même pas de la
pornographie temps l'invraisemblance de
son extrémisme tu l'excitation
on est plus proche de l'horreur que de
l'aboutissement d'ailleurs l'avis de
saab a inspiré des films d'horreur
napoléon détester saad a qualifé justin
de livres le plus abominable qui ait
enfanté l'imagination la plus d'épreuves
[Musique]
l'oeuvre du marquis ne se résume pas à
des récits dignes de films d'horreur car
il en ressort aussi une certaine
philosophie et plus particulièrement une
certaine morale ça l'a notamment
théorisé lise holisme qui est d'ailleurs
un terme de son invention
lise holisme c'est l'idée selon laquelle
autrui ne serait qu'un instrument aussi
bien le désir sexuel que dans la
relation sociale
du coup tout est permis parce qu'ils ne
font ressentir aucune empathie puisque
la souffrance d'autrui est totalement
dépourvu de valeur pour le sujet d'un
côté cette théorie est un peu
contradictoire avec l'apologie sa dite
de la liberté pour que je sois libre ma
liberté doit forcément les bornes et par
celle d'autrui et réciproquement
mais le marquis a bien mis en pratique
lise holisme dans sa vie ou plutôt il a
bien théorisé son propre comportement
il se plaisait à terroriser les femmes
qui étaient ses victimes il traitait
comme des chiens son personnel et ses
intendant avec méchanceté naturel et en
s'affranchissant de tout principe moral
il était d'un égoïsme assumer incroyable
il mentait méprisé trahissez etc
rien ne l'arrêté bref vous l'avez
compris on ne peut vraiment pas
reprocher aux marquis de sade
l'incohérence des paroles et dz je n'ai
pas trop là pour habitude de donner mon
avis mais je dois dire qu'à la lecture
de cette biographie ça ne m'apparaît
comme une vraie ratures pour ma part je
ne dirais pas le génial marquis je ne
suis pas du tout fan je ne suis pas béat
d'admiration devant la vie certains
romanesque de l'aventurier libertin
parce qu'il faut quand même le dire les
légendes sa de révolutionnaire ou ça le
libérateur des moeurs c'est du pipeau
sur le plan des faits la liberté de
sable c'est la liberté du tortionnaire
la philosophie politique de sade s'il y
en a une c'est l'inégalité radicale des
castes avec l'élite qui est autorisé à
se servir en toute impunité des sommes
inférieures comme de purs objets enfin
au point de vue moral
le marquis a quand même un caramel dans
un comportement quotidien
à en croire tous les témoignages
regroupés dans cette biographie
l'égoïsme la malhonnêteté et la
méchanceté même même et peut-être
surtout à l'égard de ses collaborateurs
de ses meilleurs amis de sa famille et
même de ses enfants
bref c'était une lecture agréable et
intéressante mais certainement pas
inspirante pour moi si vous avez aimé la
vidéo
mettez lui un pouce bleus et
abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la suivante pour
lire l'article de blogs tiré de ma
lecture ou ma synthèse sur le sadisme
qui sont sur le site mille idées de
culture générale voire pour lire cette
biographie tous les liens sont dans la
description
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser des
commentaires
enfin pour recevoir les dernières idées
de culture générale synthétisée dans le
format le plus clair possible
vous pouvez vous inscrire à la
newsletter en laissant votre adresse
email sur le site
je suis romain et vous étiez sur mille
idées de culture générale
rappelez vous vous n'avez pas besoin
d'être masochiste pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée
[Musique]